Y para convencernos de ello,
capturamos un set de datos independientes que le presentamos a nuestra red
y a 25 dermatólogos acreditados, de Stanford,
y los comparamos.
Y en la mayoría de los casos, su precisión al clasificar
fue igual o mejor que la de los dermatólogos humanos.
CA: Me contaste una anécdota,
sobre esta imagen de aquí.
¿Qué pasó aquí?
ST: Esto fue el jueves.
Lo que demostramos y publicamos en "Nature" este año
fue la idea de mostrar ciertas imágenes
a dermatólogos y a nuestro programa,
y contar cuántas veces aciertan.
Pero todas esas imágenes eran antiguas,
ya se han realizado biopsias para confirmar su clasificación.
Esta no.
Esta fue tomada en Stanford por uno de nuestros colaboradores.
Lo que sucedió fue que nuestro colaborador,
un dermatólogo reconocido internacionalmente,
de los tres mejores del mundo,
vio este lunar y dijo: "Esto no es cáncer de piel".
Y luego dudó y dijo:
"Bueno, voy a chequear con la aplicación".
Así que sacó su iPhone y abrió nuestro software,
nuestro "dermatólogo de bolsillo", por así decirlo,
y el iPhone dictaminó: cáncer.
Dijo que era melanoma.
Y el médico estaba confundido.
Y decidió, "tal vez confío más en el iPhone que en mí mismo",
y lo mandó al laboratorio para hacerle una biopsia.
Y resultó ser un melanoma muy agresivo.
Así que este puede ser el primer caso,
usando aprendizaje profundo en la práctica,
de una persona cuyo melanoma hubiera pasado sin diagnosticar
de no ser por el aprendizaje profundo.
CA: Es increíble.
(Aplausos)
Me parece que habría demanda instantánea por una aplicación como esta,
o que muchas personas se asustarían.
¿Estás pensando hacerlo? ¿Crear una aplicación de autodiagnóstico?
ST: Mi casilla está llena de correos sobre aplicaciones para cáncer,
con historias estremecedoras de gente.
Personas a quienes les han extraído 10, 15 o 20 melanomas,
y temen que alguno les pase desapercibido, como este,
pero también sobre, no sé,
coches voladores y peticiones para conferencias, supongo.
Mi opinión es que necesitamos estudiarlo más.
Quiero ser muy cuidadoso.
Es muy fácil dar un resultado ostentoso y deslumbrar al público de TED;
es mucho más difícil sacar algo ético.
Y si la gente fuera a usar esta aplicación
y decidiera no consultar con un médico
porque le dimos un mal diagnóstico,
me sentiría fatal.
Así que estamos haciendo pruebas clínicas,
y si nuestros datos aguantan,
entonces podremos tomar este tipo de tecnología,
sacarla de la clínica de Stanford
y presentarla al mundo entero,
en lugares a los que los médicos de Stanford nunca irían.
CA: Y si te entendí bien,
me parece que lo que dices es que,
como estás trabajando con este ejército de estudiantes de Udacity,
de cierta manera, estás aplicando otro modo de aprendizaje de máquina
que puede ocurrir en una compañía,
y es que estás combinando aprendizaje de máquina con sabiduría colectiva.
¿Quieres decir que de este modo se podrían sobrepasar
los resultados de una compañía, incluso una grande?
ST: Creo que hay situaciones que me asombran,
y todavía estoy intentando entender.
Chris se refiere a estas competencias que hacemos.
El tiempo de entrega es de 48 horas,
y hemos logrado construir un vehículo autónomo
que puede manejar de Mountain View a San Francisco por las calles.
No está a la par con Google pues ellos llevan siete años trabajando en esto
pero ahí va.
Y requirió solo dos ingenieros y tres meses lograrlo.
Y la razón es que tenemos un ejército de estudiantes
que participan en las competencias.
No somos los únicos que hacemos colaboración abierta:
Uber y Didi lo usan para manejar.
Airbnb lo usa para hoteles.
Ahora hay muchos ejemplos de colaboración abierta
para encontrar errores de programación,
o desdoblar proteínas, imagínense.
Pero pudimos construir este vehículo en tres meses,
así que estoy reconsiderando
cómo organizamos las empresas.
Tenemos una plantilla de 9000 personas
que no son contratadas ni despedidas.
Se presentan a trabajar y ni me entero.
Recibo 9000 proyectos.
No estoy obligado a usar ninguno de ellos.
Al final solo le pago a los que ganan,
en realidad soy muy tacaño en esto, puede que no sea lo mejor.
Y ellos lo consideran parte de su educación, que está bien.
Estos estudiantes han logrado resultados maravillosos en aprendizaje profundo.
La síntesis de buenas personas y buen aprendizaje de máquina es fenomenal.
CA: Gary Kaspárov dijo el primer día de TED2017
que los ganadores del ajedrez resultaron ser dos jugadores amateur
con tres programas de computadora semi-mediocres,
que podían superar a un gran maestro con un jugador maravilloso,
como si fuese parte del proceso.
Y casi parece que estás hablando de una versión más sofisticada
de esta misma idea.
ST: Tras asistir a los maravillosos paneles de discusión de ayer,
dos sesiones sobre IA,
"Líderes supremos robóticos" y "La respuesta humana",
se dijeron muchas cosas maravillosas.
Pero una de las preocupaciones es que a veces confundimos
lo que ya se ha logrado con IA, con este riesgo de que nos dominen,
de que la IA desarrolle consciencia, ¿cierto?
Lo último que quiero es que mi IA desarrolle consciencia.
No quiero entrar en mi cocina
y que el refrigerador se enamore de la lavadora,
y me diga que, como no fui suficientemente amable,
mi comida ahora está tibia.
Yo no compraría estos productos y no los quiero.
Pero la realidad es que, para mí,
la IA siempre ha sido un mejoramiento del hombre
de nosotros mismos,
para hacernos más fuertes.
Y creo que Kaspárov tenía razón.
Ha sido la combinación de las inteligencias humana y de máquina
lo que nos fortalece.
El tema de que las máquinas nos fortalecen es tan antiguo como las máquinas mismas.
La revolución agrícola ocurrió cuando se creó la máquina de vapor
y el equipo de cosecha que no podía manejarse solo;
no nos reemplazó, nos hizo más fuertes.
Y yo creo que esta nueva ola de IA
nos hará mucho más fuertes como seres humanos.
CA: Volveremos con eso en un momento,
pero retomando la parte alarmante para algunos,
lo que asusta a la gente es cuando tienes
una computadora que puede, primero, reescribir su propio código;
puede crear copias de sí mismo,
probar diferentes codificaciones, incluso de manera aleatoria,
y luego, probarlas y determinar si la meta se cumplió y superó.
Entonces, digamos que el objetivo es mejorar en una prueba de inteligencia.
Una computadora un tanto buena en eso,
podría intentar un millón de versiones.
Podría encontrar una mejor,
y luego, ya sabes, repetir.
Entonces la preocupación es que se salga de control,
donde todo esté bien el jueves por la noche,
pero regresas al laboratorio el viernes por la mañana,
y por la velocidad misma de la computadora,
las cosas se hayan alocado y de pronto...
ST: Diría que sí es una posibilidad,
pero una posibilidad muy remota.
Déjame traducir lo que acabas de decir.
En el caso de AlphaGo tuvimos justamente eso:
La computadora jugaba contra sí misma
y aprendía reglas nuevas.
Y el aprendizaje de máquina es reescribir esas reglas,
reescribir el código.
Pero no había miedo alguno
de que AlphaGo se apoderara del mundo.
Ni siquiera puede jugar al ajedrez.
CA: No, no, no, pero estas cosas son de un campo muy limitado.
Pero es posible imaginar...
acabamos de ver una computadora que era casi capaz
de aprobar un examen de ingreso a la universidad;
no puede leer y comprender como nosotros podemos,
pero, desde luego, puede asimilar todo el texto
y tal vez identificar patrones de significado.
¿No existe la posibilidad, conforme esto se expande,
que pudiera salirse de control?
ST: Ahí pinto la raya, francamente.
Y la posibilidad existe -- no quiero restarle importancia --
pero es remota y no es algo que ocupe mi mente ahora,
porque la gran revolución es otra cosa.
Todo lo que ha salido bien con la IA hasta el día de hoy
ha sido extremadamente especializado,
y ha prosperado en una sola idea,
que es cantidades masivas de datos.
AlphaGo funciona tan bien por la gran cantidad de jugadas de go,
y AlphaGo no puede manejar un auto ni volar un avión.
El vehículo autónomo de Google o el de Udacity
prosperan por la gran cantidad de datos y no pueden hacer otra cosa;
ni siquiera puede controlar una motocicleta.
Es una función muy específica,
y lo mismo sucede con la app del cáncer.
Prácticamente no ha habido progreso en lo que llamamos "IA general",
en que puedas decirle, "inventa la teoría de la relatividad especial
o la teoría de cuerdas".
Está en pañales.
Y quiero hacer hincapié en esto,
porque veo la preocupación que existe y la reconozco.
Pero si fuese a pensar en algo, sería:
"¿Qué tal si podemos tomar cualquier actividad repetitiva
y hacernos 100 veces más eficientes?"
Resulta que hace 100 años todos trabajábamos en el campo
y cultivábamos y hacíamos cosas repetitivas.
Hoy, el 75 % de nosotros trabaja en una oficina
y hacemos cosas repetitivas.
Nos hemos convertido en hojas de cálculo humanas.
Y no solo los trabajos básicos.
Nos hemos hecho dermatólogos que hacen cosas repetitivas,
abogados que hacen cosas repetitivas.
Creo que estamos al borde de poder tomar la IA,
echar un vistazo atrás,
y hacernos tal vez 10 o 50 veces más efectivos en estas cosas repetitivas.
Eso es lo que ocupa mi mente.
CA: Pues suena muy emocionante.
El proceso para llegar ahí suena aterrador para algunas personas,
porque una vez que la computadora pueda realizar esta actividad repetitiva
mucho mejor que un dermatólogo,
o que el conductor, es de lo que tanto se habla ahora,
de pronto se pierden millones de empleos
y, ya sabes, el país se revoluciona
antes de que podamos alcanzar los aspectos más espectaculares posibles.
ST: Sí, y eso es un problema, un gran problema,
y lo mencionaban ayer por la mañana varios oradores.
Antes de subir al escenario
confesé que soy una persona positiva y optimista,
así que déjame darte mi discurso optimista
que es: imagínense a Uds. mismos hace 300 años.
Europa acababa de sobrevivir 140 años de guerra continua,
nadie sabía leer o escribir,
no existían los trabajos de hoy,
como banca de inversiones o ingeniero de software o conductor de TV.
Todos estaríamos en los campos, cultivando.
Y por aquí llega el pequeño Sebastian con una máquina de vapor en su bolsillo,
diciendo: "¡Ei, chicos! Vean esto.
Esto los va a hacer 100 veces más fuertes para que puedan hacer otra cosa".
Y en ese entonces no había escenario
pero Chris y yo nos reuníamos en el establo de las vacas,
y me dice: "estoy muy preocupado,
porque ordeño a mi vaca a diario,
y ¿qué pasará cuando esta máquina lo haga por mí?"
Les digo esto porque,
somos muy buenos reconociendo el progreso pasado y sus beneficios,
como el iPhone o los aviones, la electricidad o los utensilios médicos.
Nos encanta vivir hasta los 80 años, lo cual era imposible hace 300 años.
Pero no aplicamos el mismo razonamiento hacia el futuro.
Si tomo mi propio trabajo como CEO,
diría que el 90 % de lo que hago es repetitivo,
no lo disfruto,
paso cuatro horas al día en emails estúpidos y repetitivos.
Y muero por tener algo que me ayude a librarme de esto.
¿Por qué?
Porque creo que todos somos extremadamente creativos;
la comunidad de TED en particular.
Pero hasta los obreros; creo que si toman un trago
con la empleada o el empleado de un hotel,
una hora después encontrarán allí una idea creativa.
Esto permitirá convertir esa creatividad en acción.
¿Qué tal si pudieras inventar Google en un día?
¿Qué tal si tomaras una cerveza e inventaras el siguiente Snapchat,
lo que sea,
y para mañana ya está en operación?
No es ciencia ficción.
Lo que va a suceder es,
que ya somos historia.
Hemos desatado esta asombrosa creatividad
emancipándonos del campo
y luego, claro, de las fábricas,
y hemos inventado muchas cosas.
Va a ser aún mejor, en mi opinión.
Y los efectos colaterales serán maravillosos.
Uno de ellos será
que cosas como la comida, los aparatos médicos,
la educación, la vivienda y el transporte,
serán mucho más asequibles para todos,
no solo para las personas ricas.
CA: Mmm.
Cuando Martin Ford explicaba que esta vez será distinto
porque la inteligencia que hemos usado en el pasado
para buscar caminos nuevos
será igualada al mismo ritmo
por las computadoras que las relevarán...
lo que tú dices es que, no del todo,
por la creatividad humana.
¿Crees que eso sea fundamentalmente distinto del tipo de creatividad
que tienen las computadoras?
ST: Estoy convencido, como experto en IA,
que no he visto progreso real en lo referente a creatividad
y pensamiento fuera de lo convencional.
Lo que veo ahora, y es importante que la gente lo entienda,
porque el concepto "inteligencia artificial" es muy aterrador,
tenemos a Steven Spielberg que crea una película,
y de pronto la computadora es nuestro líder supremo,
pero en realidad es una tecnología.
Es la tecnología la que nos ayuda a hacer actividades repetitivas.
Se ha logrado progreso en las actividades repetitivas.
En encontrar documentos legales,
en redactar contratos.
En analizar exámenes de rayos X del pecho.
Y son cosas tan especializadas,
que no veo la gran amenaza para la humanidad.
De hecho, nosotros como personas...
seamos realistas: nos hemos vuelto súper-humanos,
nos hemos hecho súper-humanos.
Podemos cruzar el Atlántico nadando en 11 horas.
Podemos sacar un aparato del bolsillo
y hacer un llamado a Australia,
y en tiempo real la otra persona nos responde alto y claro.
Eso es físicamente imposible, rompe las reglas de la Física.
Al final, vamos a recordar
todo lo que has dicho y lo que has visto,
recordarás a cada persona,
lo cual es bueno en mi etapa inicial de Alzheimer.
Disculpa, ¿qué estaba diciendo? Lo olvidé.
CA: (Risas)
ST: Probablemente tendremos un coeficiente intelectual de 1000 o más.
No habrá más clases de ortografía para los niños
porque ya no existirán los errores de ortografía.
No habrá problemas con las matemáticas.
Y entonces sucederá que seremos súper creativos.
Y lo somos. Somos creativos.
Esa es nuestra arma secreta.
CA: Así que los empleos se van a eliminar,
de cierto modo, aunque va a ser doloroso,
los humanos somos capaces de más que esos trabajos.
Este es el sueño.
El sueño es que los humanos alcancen un nuevo nivel de empoderamiento
y descubrimiento.
Ese es el sueño.
ST: Y piensa en esto;
si ves la historia de la humanidad,
que serán unos 60 a 100 000 años, más o menos,
casi todo lo que apreciamos en cuanto a invenciones,
de tecnología, de lo que hemos construido,
se ha inventado en los últimos 150 años.
Si le agregas el libro y la rueda, es un poco más.
O el hacha.
Pero tu teléfono, tus zapatillas,
estas sillas, la manufactura moderna, la penicilina...
las cosas que atesoramos.
Ahora, para mí eso significa
que en los próximos 150 años encontraremos más cosas.
De hecho, el ritmo de invención ha subido, no bajado, en mi opinión.
Creo que se han creado solo el 1 % de las cosas interesantes.
¿Cierto?
No hemos curado el cáncer.
No tenemos coches voladores, todavía. Espero cambiar esto.
Ese ejemplo solía provocar risas.
(Risas)
Es gracioso, ¿no es cierto? Trabajar en secreto en coches voladores.
Todavía no vivimos el doble de años.
No tenemos este implante mágico en el cerebro
que nos dé la información que buscamos.
Y puede parecer aberrante,
pero les prometo que cuando lo tengan les encantará.
Espero que les encante.
Es un poco alarmante, lo sé.
Hay muchas cosas que todavía no inventamos,
que inventaremos.
No tenemos escudos de gravedad.
No podemos teletransportarnos.
Suena ridículo, pero hace 200 años,
los expertos opinaban que no se podría volar,
incluso hace 120 años,
y que si te movías más rápido de lo que podías correr,
morirías al instante.
Así que, ¿quién puede estar seguro hoy
de que no se pueda teletransportar a una persona de aquí a Marte?
CA: Sebastian, muchas gracias
por tu increíble visión inspiradora y tu genialidad.
Gracias, Sebastian Thrun.
ST: Fue fantástico. (Aplausos)